bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat hier soir les
sénateurs ont poursuivi la réforme
monsieur raso sur l'enseignement
supérieur et la recherche
un texte qui est examiné en procédure
accélérée qui a été voté par les députés
le 28 mai ils lisent deux objectifs
principaux d'abord la réussite des 2,3
millions d'étudiants
le gouvernement va atteindre 50 % de
diplômés dans le supérieur au lieu de
40% actuellement les bacheliers
technologiques et professionnels 50 %
des bacheliers d'aujourd'hui seront donc
en priorité orientés vers des filières
courtes
la licence sera également réformé pour
devenir beaucoup plus généraliste la
première année avec une spécialisation
progressive les années suivantes
le second volet de cette réforme vise à
améliorer l'attractivité de la recherche
ce qui passe par un toilettage de la loi
lru de 2007 sur l'autonomie des
universités ainsi que du pacte de
recherche de 2006 les sénateurs
communistes voteront contre ce texte qui
ne rompt pas selon eu suffisamment avec
le passé les écologistes regrettent
qu'il laisse peu de place aux chercheurs
et aux enseignants et souhaite refaire
fonctionner l'ascenseur social
on le voit donc l'adoption de ce texte
s'avère d'ores et déjà difficile
le gouvernement ne disposant que d'une
très courte majorité de 6 voir ici au
sénat mais sans plus tarder direction
l'hémicycle pour l'examen de cette
réforme fioraso très bonne matinée à
tous sur notre chaîne l'ordre du jour
appelle la suite de la discussion du
projet de loi adopté par l'assemblée
nationale après engagement de la
procédure accélérée relatifs à
l'enseignement supérieur à la recherche
la discussion générale est close nous
passons la discussion d'un motion
tendant à opposer la question préalable
madame sophie primas et les membres du
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
ont déposé une motion distribuée sous le
numéro 2 157 tendant à opposer la
question préalable texte en discussion
monsieur savin une pause en tête le
motion s'il vous plaît
le site
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mesdames les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues mais la ministre
si nous ne doutons pas de votre
implication de votre volonté à vouloir
améliorer le fonctionnement de notre
système de l'enseignement supérieur la
recherche
nous sommes nombreux à ressentir un
sentiment d'inachevé à l'issue de cette
discussion générale
en effet les interventions de mes
collègues du groupe ump mais aussi de
nos collègues des groupe u10 écologistes
et communistes ont mis en avant les
insuffisances et les nombreuses
interrogations sur ce projet de loi
tout d'abord cela a été rappelé à
plusieurs reprises
ce projet de loi n'est pas un texte de
programmation hors définir une politique
pour l'enseignement supérieur et la
recherche nécessite l'attribution de
moyens
le projet de loi se veut peut être
ambitieux dans le discours mais sans le
déblocage de nouveaux moyens financiers
il ne peut y avoir de démarche crédible
ensuite rien dans ce projet de justifie
la remise en cause de la loi libertés et
responsabilités des universités de 2007
les principales modifications prévues
vont au contraire porter atteinte aux
marges de manoeuvre de nos universités
et organismes de recherche
enfin les conditions d'examen du texte
ne sont pas à la hauteur du sujet étudié
premiers points cette loi n'est pas une
loi de programmation
alors que le gouvernement précédent
avait consacré des moyens très
importants à notre système
d'enseignement supérieur et de recherche
vous refusé de prendre des engagements
financiers
vous ne donnez ainsi aucune visibilité à
nos chercheurs et un aux présidents
d'université
certes
le contexte budgétaire est contraint
mais il s'agit de fixer des priorités et
le secteur de l'économie de la
connaissance est précisément celui qui
détermine l'avenir de nos enfants et
notre position dans la compétition
mondiale le gouvernement précédent
l'avait bien compris entre 2007 et 2012
le budget des universités a augmenté en
moyenne de 25% pour un total de neuf
milliards d'euros
onze mille 500 postes ont été créés
depuis 2003 et 380 millions d'euros ont
permis de revaloriser leur carrière en
matière de recherche 22 milliard ont été
inscrits au titre des investissements
d'avenir
cela dans un contexte budgétaire déjà
difficile mais le gouvernement de
françois fillon avait su faire preuve de
choix ait eu le courage de choisir
second point il n'y aucune raison de
bouleverser ce qui était formée il ya
cinq ans il faut laisser le temps
réforme d'ampleur de s'installer
pourquoi remettre en cause au bout de 5
ans la gouvernance des universités en
installant deux conseils qui risque
d'être rivaux l'autonomie a permis des
avancées spectaculaires
personne ne remet sérieusement cela en
question
selon certains recteurs vous allez
engager un nivellement par le bas et
transformer nos universités en navire
ingouvernable pourquoi supprimer l'
agence d'évaluation mise en place pour
le substituer une autorité
administrative dans les missions et les
pouvoirs ne sont pas si différents
pourquoi regrouper les universités en
complexifiant leur organisation
ainsi nous aurons l'état qui exercera sa
tutelle le conseil de chaque communauté
qui sera placé au dessus des conseils de
chaque établissement eux mêmes divisés
en conseil d'administration et
conseiller académique
pourquoi vous attaquez au réseau
d'excellence en supprimant les pôles de
recherche et d'enseignement supérieur
dont la création contrairement aux
communautés que vous mettez
place était librement décidée par les
établissements à toutes ces questions la
réponse est purement politique
non il n'y avait pas urgence à légiférer
il suffisait tout d'abord de prendre en
compte les conclusions du rapport de le
collègue dominique gillot et ambroise
dupont issus des amiraux cli auprès des
présidents d'université en améliorant
certains points de la loi lru
on pouvait par exemple revoir la place
de l'entreprise dans le conseil
d'administration et le rôle des
personnes qualifiées
augmenter le poids des missions
d'orientation et d'insertion
professionnelle confiée aux universités
sujet primordial pour lutter contre
l'échec en première année ou en licence
en somme on aurait pu tout simplement
moderniser le système mis en place en
au lieu de mettre en place une contre
réforme de plus cette modernisation doit
avoir la légitimité démocratique d'une
large concertation construite avec
l'ensemble des acteurs du monde
universitaire sur son organisation sur
ses finalités sur les moyens financiers
mobilisés sur l'orientation des
étudiants sur les liens entre université
et recherche sur la question du logement
et bien d'autres sujets enfin nous
estimons que les conditions d'un examen
rigoureux de ce projet de loi n'ont pas
été remplis à plus d'un titre
vous avez d'abord souhaité que l'urgence
soit déclaré
or ce texte comporte 70 articles parfois
très techniques notamment en ce qui
concerne la recherche ou les conditions
de réforme territoriale
vous nous contraignait à une seule
lecture du texte alors que certains
sujets la gouvernance
l'évaluation les communautés
nécessiterait des échanges nourris entre
les deux chambres la revue l'heureuse
revalorisation du parlement souhaitait
et ces dernières années passe par des
conditions correctes d'examen des tests
qui sont présentés aux parlementaires si
nous avons le temps d'étudier
attentivement les dispositions du projet
de loi la qualité de notre travail ne
sera que meilleur madame la ministre
pour conclure parce que les conditions
d'un examen attentif de ce projet de loi
n'ont pas été réunies et que la nature
même du texte n'est pas satisfaisante
nous estimons qu'il n'ya pas lieu de
l'étudiant l'état je remets gros merci
merci mon cher collègue
la parole est un monsieur david
assouline contre la motion
oui madame la ministre monsieur le
président la mli rapporteur et président
de commission
mes chers collègues les arguments qui
sont avancés pour cette motion ne
tiennent pas debout
c'est souvent l'exercice de style pour
prendre un peu plus de temps de parole
mais là franchement les deux arguments à
avancer pour dire qu'il n'ya pas lieu de
légiférer
prenons les au pied de la lettre alors
le premier il n'y aurait pas de
programmation et d'engagement budgétaire
enfin il faut choisir parce que nous
sortons d'un débat qui a été fructueux
sur la loi sur la refondation de l'école
et vous aviez posé une question de
renvoi la même et vous disiez exactement
l inverse il ne convenait pas de
légiférer parce que il ne fallait pas
programmer des moyens à un moment donné
où le budget de l'état et contrat
c'est-à-dire que vous nous reprocher
d'avoir fait une loi de programmation
pour demander cette question de rejet
ont aujourd'hui vous faites exactement
l'inversé
alors pour la crédibilité de votre
argumentation
eh bien vous repasserez en réalité vous
argumentez aussi et je crois que madame
prima n'a pas dû bien revoir les débats
qu'il y à eut alors ici mais la ministre
l'a mentionné hier
vous vous appuyez sur le fait que la
haye les ruelles étaient une loi de
programmation
eh bien non regardez les textes c'est ne
s'était pas la programmation et moi j'ai
relu mon intervention de l'époque
c'était un reproche que l'on pouvait
faire parce que quand on fait de tels
transferts
quand on modifie à ce point les ce truc
et qu'il n'ya pas un euro à côté cas au
moment où légifèrent alors là vraiment
il y a un problème alors les deux
arguments sur la question de la
programmation sont contradictoires avec
ce que vous avez fait au moment de la
rue est-ce que vous avez déclaré
ici encore récemment au moment de la loi
sur l'école vous reprocher qu'il n'y
aurait pas de moyens la ministre a
rappelé non seulement ce qui est
programmé les 5000 postes sur la
mandature c'est à dire mille postes mais
centré sur la réussite notamment premier
cycle et non pas en général parce que
nous avons identifié que le sujet majeur
pour les étudiants était celui là et
vous vous appuyez sur des chiffres que
vous avez inventé pour nous dire que
dans la mandature précédente des moyens
gigantesques avaient été déployés pour
accompagner la loi lru pour la réussite
notamment sur la recherche alors sous le
gouvernement fillon en euros constants
et à périmètre constant
et quand on parle sinon vaut mieux être
précis à leur constant et à périmètre
constant c'est-à-dire hors pensions
crédit impôt recherche et
investissements d'avenir donc au budget
de la mission interministérielle
recherche et enseignement supérieur
était en 2012 inférieur à celui de 2007
il avait une régression
cinq ans après par rapport à 2007
lang almès lsi stress et les lignes et
d'ailleurs vous devriez quand vous
faites ce genre de procès vous rapporter
à des rapports parce que nous
travaillons ici à faire des rapports
d'évaluation etc
ça serait bien de les lire madame gillot
et monsieur haguenau ont fait un rapport
qui montre bien ça et regarder les
grilles et monsieur dupont peut en
témoigner parce que lui en faisant un
autre rapport sur la loi lru
regard nécessite l'engagement de nicolas
sarkozy au début de son quinquennat
était d'augmenter 1 2 1 milliards 8 par
an le budget de l'enseignement supérieur
et de la recherche depuis l'annnonce du
grand emprunt en 2010 les crédits
destinés à cette mission ont chuté de
près de 5% soit plus que ce que devait
rapporter annuellement les intérêts du
grand emprunt
en 2011 comme en 2010 l'évolution du
budget de la mire a été inférieur au
montant défini pour la programmation
budgétaire pluriannuelle qui prévoyait
des hausses successives de plus de 3% en
2010 +3 6% en 2011 25 183 milliards 25
milles 180 3 milliards contre 25
milliards huit cent soixante six mille
prévus pour 2011 et c'est sur l'ensemble
de la législature les crédits de la mire
n'ont progressé que de 3 8 milliards
sans tenir compte de l'inflation
on est loin des 1,8 milliard annuel et
même de la promesse du candidat sarkozy
de cinq milliards supplémentaires
par contre le gouvernement de monsieur
ayrault dans un contexte budgétaire
d'austérité à augmenter les crédits de
la mission pour 2013
de plus j'ai recul de 16%
austérité au niveau européen nous ici
celle inverse puisqu'il y à une
augmentation de + gyr gül 2 16% avec le
gouvernement de monsieur ayrault
deuxième argument pour en finir vous à
vous avancez dans votre question
préalable
l'idée qu'il n'ya pas lieu de légiférer
parce qu'il ya rien de nouveau
je prends votre question que à la
rigueur par rapport à la loi lru
il ya quelques aménagements mais la
ministre hier nous a répondu qu'il faut
choisir les arguments où vous dites
qu'on a tous détricoter et que c'est une
contre loi par rapport
la loi lru ou vous dites qu a pas lieu
de légiférer parce que il n'ya pas grand
chose au delà des grandes intentions
alors moi je vais vous je vais pas
décliner toutes les raisons de légiférer
m'enfin ici la concertation dont vous
que vous avez critiqué qu'il manquerait
ses vingt mille personnes pendant
plusieurs mois qui ont participé à cette
concertation qui quel que soit bien sûr
les avis divergent dans cette
concertation tous disait qu'on ne
pouvait pas continuer avec l'état actuel
de la législation
et d'ailleurs même quand vous critiquez
cette loi est d'ailleurs même quand vous
critiquez cette loi et vous déclinez
tout ce qu'on aurait pu faire pour ne
pas la remettre en cause globalement à
chaque fois ce que vous citez monsieur
nécessite de légiférer même les petites
questions que vous avez posé et quand
vous vous appuyez sur le rapport de
monsieur du point de madame gino pour
dire il aurait suffi de faire si ça et
ça a cette fois il faut légiférer pour
faire si ça et ça et donc par rapport à
votre question la façon dont vous
argumentez et bien il y a des arguments
qui ne tiennent pas la concertation a eu
lieu alors que sur la lru qui modifiait
profondément les structures ça s'est
fait à la va-vite l'été en quelques
jours après le conseil des ministres
sans avoir à aucun moment essayé de
rassembler la communauté universitaire
puisque vous avez attendu justement
qu'elles soient en vacances pour
légiférer parce que vous aviez peur
d'affronter leurs poignets c'est comme
ça oui oui mais je lui ai déjà dit à
l'époque je lui ai déjà dit à l'époque
ici parce que quelle que soit la
conviction qu'elle avait sur sa loi
c'était nécessaire d'en discuter puisque
elle était sûre de son fait et elle
était sûre même du soutien qu'elle
pouvait apporter en scène au début du
mois
depuis ici quelques jours après
l'annonce que nous avons dû légiférer
effectivement nous sommes rentrés dans
ce débat de façon constructive pour
essayer à partir de l'autonomie qui
était nécessaire de faire que la
réussite en premier cycle soit au coeur
de la loi et ça n'a pas été le cas
aujourd'hui nous sommes obligés madame
la ministre est obligé de revenir là
dessus car cinq ans après les résultats
en premier cycle se sont aggravées voilà
je veux finir en vous disant que les
différentes expertises prouve qu'il ya
lieu de légiférer et de redonner un
souffle à l'enseignement supérieur à la
recherche en revenant sur la loi lru
dont les sénateurs socialistes avaient
dès le début en séance en soi ce en 2006
pour la recherche et en 2007 pointer les
principaux points d'achoppement recul de
la démocratie au sein des instances
universitaires au profit d'une
présidentialisation du système étudiants
parents pauvres de la réforme
les rares dispositions contre les
concernant ont été issus d'amendements
socialistes absence de mesures
permettant d'envisager un rapprochement
universités grandes écoles
avec cette loi nous corrigeons tout ce
qu'il manquait dans la loi nous nous
appuyons et nous actons tout ce qui a
été positif et nous créons une cohérence
qui manquait jusque alors entre
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
qui ne sont pas traités dans de loi
séparé mais dans une seule cette loi
était attendue elle est nécessaire elle
va porter ses fruits et il y a lieu de
légiférer dit mon cher collègue demandé
l'avis de la commission sur 7
l'avis de la commission
avis défavorable bien évidemment à vis
du gouvernement madame le ministre
même avis favorable explications de vote
je rappelle que chaque groupe peut
exprimer pour cinq minutes
oui monsieur le président madame à
ministre mes chers collègues il est
indéniable qu'une loi de programmation
et de moyens et d'emploi dans
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
aurait été la bienvenue notamment eu
égard à l'ampleur de la précarité dont
j'ai parlé hier et j'avais également
lire dans la discussion générale eu
l'occasion de dire les nombreuses
objections pour ne pas dire plus qui
conduiront à ce que mon groupe se
prononce contre ce projet de loi
cependant nous ne voterons pas en faveur
de cette question préalable de nos
collègues ump car les raisons de notre
opposition à ce texte sont strictement
opposées holler ce projet de loi
considérons nous n'aurons ni avec la lru
ni même avec le pacte de recherche de
2006 et même j'entendais qu'on parlait
tout à l'heure du rôle de la rs
ce qui est proposé ne nous satisfait pas
non plus et donc on se trouve plutôt
pensant nous dans une forme de
continuité
de plus nous pensons que le débat
parlementaire a son utilité
parce qu'il va nous permettre
d'identifier les points du débat les
divergences et de faire cheminer je
l'espère la réflexion et nous serons
ainsi je pense contributif à faire
prévaloir dans un futur proche des
éléments propres et de progrès pour
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
merci madame blue monsieur le président
madame la ministre mesdames madame la
présidente de commission
madame la présidente de commission pour
avis madame la rapporteure mes chers
collègues visiblement ce type de motion
fait partie de nos rituels et nous
sommes très attachés aux traditions et
aux rituels pour autant nous
désapprouvons totalement l'analyse qui a
été faite
y compris d'être repris dans
l'argumentaire même si l'on peut y voir
un clin d'oeil
je voudrais revenir sur ce qui a été dit
hier est rappelé que pour ce qui
concerne le tableau de la situation
actuelle de la recherche le tableau
désastreux de la situation de
l'université tel que l'a trouvée madame
la ministre nous sommes assez d'accord
avec les conclusions hier qui ont été
présentés sur la situation
catastrophique qu'il y a et donc même si
ces bancs sont quelque peu clairsemé on
peut le regretter ça montre peut-être
une faible appétence de nos collègues
pour un débat compliqué avec beaucoup de
concepts avec des choses extrêmement
battus en termes de gouvernance moi je
regrette que nous ne soyons pas plus
nombreux pour parler quand même quelques
sujets majeurs de ce texte qui est la
réussite étudiante et l'avenir de
l'université de la recherche
et même si concernant les remèdes qui
sont apportées nous avons fait part de
nos satisfactions même si nous
regrettons le manque de moyens même si
nous avons eu hier sollennellement fait
un appel pour un milliards du crédit
impôt recherche réorienter réinjecter
vers l'enseignement et la recherche
nous pensons que ce débat est un débat
tout à fait crucial que les oppositions
mérite d'être dit que les contradictions
démocratie mérite d'être posée et que
c'est une posture tout à fait
politicienne que de déposer sur ce type
ce type de sur ce sujet ce type de
motion qui ne reçoit absolument pas
notre accord donc compte tenu de tous
ces arguments
le groupe écologiste votera contre cette
motion et réitère son souhait d'un débat
contradictoire fait d'avancé fait de
proposition et ça n'est pas parce qu'un
texte n'est pas satisfaisant quand il
arrive au sénat qu'il faut considérer
que le débat n'a pas lieu d'être
sinon mes chers collègues et bien pour
faire des économies et ben on demande la
suppression du sénat
si c'est ça notre conception du travail
parlementaire faisons des économies donc
nous nous sommes attachés au travail de
la haute assemblée nous sommes persuadés
que ce débat un sens que madame la
ministre a une vision politique même si
nous avons des désaccords sur certains
points on est là pour faire la politique
et pour parler de l'enseignement
supérieur et la recherche et dernier
point
moi j'ai parlé avec un certain nombre de
collègues et c'est ça qui m'alerte ici
presque personne n'a d'enfants à
l'université
tous les enfants sont en bts sont nulles
t son école ingénieur / en école de
commerce
alors évidemment le sort de l'université
le sort de la recherche peut nous
paraître lointain certains d'entre nous
est bien ici nous sommes là pour faire
la loi pour défendre l'intérêt général
pour défendre le service public pour
défendre l'université française pour
défendre l'égalité devant les
territoires donc il faut un état
stratège et même si on a des désaccords
sur certains points de cette loi nous
devons en parler c'est tout la vertu de
la démocratie est l'intérêt de cette
hausse a semblé toujours merci merci la
parole à monsieur mercier
merci beaucoup monsieur le président je
dire d'abord notre collègue et moi je
suis universitaire et que je me sens
très bien à l'université que j'ai qu'une
envie d'en discuter de la défendre notre
groupe est rentré dans cette discussion
madame la ministre avec l'esprit ouvert
peut-être même sur you do aller très
loin dans l'ouverture parce que nous
avions compris que vous étiez de presse
vous madame le rapporteur a accepté un
certain nombre d'amendements
nous les avons travaillé tous ont été
rejetés après l'intervention de monsieur
assouline qui vient encore de nous
convaincre ici de son grand degré
d'ouverture sur ce texte et je le
regrette profondément
je ne regrette profondément parce que
madame je crois aux débats
parlementaires mais si on nous dit avant
que le débat s'engage il n'y a rien à
discuter tous vos amendements sont
rejetés alors que nous étions prêts et
je le dis à titre personnel probablement
à voter le texte et qu'on nous envoie
qu'on nous envoie comme ça comme s'il
n'y avait rien à dire rien à faire
vraiment je le regrette
c'est la négation du débat parlementaire
je regrette beaucoup cette position et
c'est ce qui le conduit après
l'intervention de monsieur assouline à
dire que d'autres groupes à l'unanimité
votre à la motion si monsieur legendre
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues à la suite de
l'intervention dans un bouche-trou je
crois que chacun doit devoir préciser
s'il sort de l'université publique ou
pas c'est mon cas je sors de
l'université et j'en suis fier et si nos
enfants sont allés à l'université
c'est le cas des miens donc je peux
prendre la parole je voudrais regretté
que ce débat qui pourrait être un débat
effectivement au nous essayons les uns
ou les autres de nous comprendre et
d'échanger des arguments tout d'abord
c'est pas un très bon signe et est
déclaré en procédure accélérée
d'un côté on débat à lesquin du
parlement mais au parlement on nous
contraint dans le temps ça ça n'est pas
le fait de l'opposition
c'est bien un choix et vision du
gouvernement j'ai fait des reproches
parfois à monsieur peillon mais je
remarque que lui n'avait pas limiter le
débat sur les autres périodes du système
scolaire
alors voilà déjà une raison de regretter
que ce débat soit organisé de cette
manière
joyon aussi qu'il est un petit peu
curieux d'un reproché à l'opposition
quand on est dans la majorité de
recourir aux procédures qui sont légales
comme le dépôt de différentes motions
alors que vous l'avez tellement fait
quand vous étiez vous même dans
l'opposition
je dirais que oublier ce que l'on a fait
avant ou ensuite nous le reprocher c'est
aussi une façon de faire un peu
politicienne et ça n'a pas beaucoup
d'intérêt
alors laissons ces arguments mes chers
collègues de côté le débat nous le
pensons ne se présente malheureusement
pas jouer meilleurs auspices nous avons
proposé d'y mettre un terme
maintenant je crois qu'ils argument qui
aurait exprimé au nom du groupe ump par
notre collègue et tous sont tout à fait
convaincant je regrette
monsieur assouline que vous ayez un peu
laborieusement permettez moi de vous le
dire essayer de justifier par des
raisons financières
la comparaison en faveur du au
gouvernement ce que vous estimez être
dans le domaine de l'enseignement
supérieur personne n'a oublié que grâce
à la loi de madame pécresse
les choses ont bougé et que c'est toi
était accompagné de différents moyens et
crédit qui ont permis de mettre en route
des opérations tout à fait importante
c'est tellement vrai que les universités
qui ne bénéficiaient pas par exemple du
plan campus s'en plaigne améliore pas
améliorée s'en plaignaient amèrement
alors on ne se plaint pas de ce qui
n'existe pas
si elles s'en sont plaint si bien parce
qu'elles y ont vu là l'occasion d'une
manne et d'un financement important
laissons de côté des polémiques sur ce
point le débat aurait dû avoir lieu nous
semble-t-il dans de meilleures
conditions
nous avons déposé un amendement pour
abréger ses débats bien évidemment le
groupe ump le votera merci monsieur
philippe adnot vous remercie monsieur le
président les les membres de la réunion
des non inscrits voteront pour la motion
de renvoi sauf moi je suis défavorable à
cette idée qu'un parlement soto limites
dans la capacité à examiner un texte que
l'émotion viennent de gauche ou de
droite
personnellement il sera toujours temps à
la fin du texte de décider de ce qu'on a
envie de faire mais ne pas l'examiner je
trouve serait ridicule
merci madame laborde monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues j'ai repris ma place au nom du
fds eux pour ne pas mélanger les genres
et donc je vous exprime aussi le vote de
la majorité des membres du rds ce contre
la motion puisque nous pouvons faire un
certain nombre de reproches
c'est ce que j'ai entendu d'un côté dire
qu'il n'y a pas de possibilité de
discuter pas de possibilité d'exprimer
son point de vue
et c'est incompatible avec l'idée de
voter une motion de renvoi
donc je vous remercie et notre vote sera
de discuter ce texte de loi
merci le personne ne demande la parole
je vais donc consulté le sénat sur la
question préalable opposé par madame
sophie primas et les membres du groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire et
dont l'adoption aurait pour effet
d'entraîner le rejet du texte en
discussion
je suis saisi de demandes de scrutins
public lui ne présentait pas monsieur
assouline au nom du groupe socialiste
l'eau pendant prima au titre de l'ump je
vous rappelle mes chers collègues que
l'avis de la commission est défavorable
à vis du gouvernement est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques instants
le scrutin est ouvert
le demande à voter le scrutin est clos
j'invite donc mesdames messieurs ce
cratère a procédé au dépouillement de ce
scrutin
du châle collègues s'ils voulaient bien
la séance et reprise résultats du
scrutin numéro 2 173 sur la motion
tendance à opposer la question préalable
au projet de loi relatif à
l'enseignement supérieur à la recherche
nombre de votants 347 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 347 pour l'adoption
170 contre 177 le sénat n'a donc pas
adoptée nous passons donc aux articles
article 1er la suppression est maintenu
article 1er bis je suis saisi de deux
amendements en discussion commune le 312
pardon la miss excusez moi je n'ai pas
vu pardonnez moi je t'en prie monsieur
le président merci je voudrais remercier
les groupes et groupe et c'est le groupe
écologiste et et monsieur le sénateur
philippe adnot parce que je pense
qu'effectivement c'est important d'avoir
un débat d'abord parce que c'est un
sujet qui doit rassembler toutes nos
préoccupations même si on peut regretter
qu effectivement il ne mobilise pas
davantage de deux parlementaires mais
c'est la même chose à l'assemblée
nationale mais les parlementaires qui
sont là en général sont passionnés donc
la qualité prévaut sur sur la quantité
parfois et puis on peut avoir des débats
plus sereins quand on n'est pas sous
cette pression médiatique parfois qui
qui comment dire suscite des envolées ou
vous des phrases un peu définitif
définitif qui ne sont pas l'état
d'esprit qui convient à la recherche et
à l'enseignement supérieur
ce que je veux dire c'est mon état
d'esprit de suivant si j'ai voulu faire
les assises de l'enseignement supérieur
et de la recherche qui ont permis de
consulter 20000 acteur je le dis au
passage au sénateur michel savin
ex-collègue rhônalpins donc je le lui
dis courtoisement mais tout de même
clairement ces assises ont permis de
consulter 20000 acteurs ce n'est pas
rien si nous avons pris si j'ai voulu
prendre six mois et ne pas agir dans la
précipitation en détricotant
effectivement une loi sans consultation
préalable
c'est bien parce qu'il me semblait qu'il
fallait consulter consulter largement
consulté l'ensemble des acteurs
et les étudiants sont des acteurs aussi
essentiel qu'il ne faut jamais oublier
parce que l'avenir c'est eux et je
dirais plutôt les étudiants que que les
enfants je ne confonds pas mes enfants
que les étudiants donc c'est vraiment la
jeunesse qui est l'avenir de ce pays
il fallait prendre le temps de les
consulter et c'est pourquoi nous avons
pris ces six mois de consultations 20000
acteurs 1300 contribution trois jours de
tables rondes eux sur les territoires et
ensuite ramassés en ile-de-france en 35
propositions
effectivement pour une loi d'orientation
tout comme la loi lru d'ailleurs qui est
également une loi d'orientation et des
moyens tout de même affirmé d'une part
dans la loi sur la refondation de
l'école de la république avec 5000
postes affirmé et consolidé pendant la
mandature pendant le quinquennat
également confirmé inscrit dans la loi
de finances pluriannuelle qui a été
votée 28 décembre dernier un plan de
résop de résorption qui a été engagée et
chiffrait à hauteur de 2100
titularisation à l'université par an
pendant quatre ans ce qui permet de
résorber la précarisation de 8400
personnel dans dans l'université et un
dialogue social qui s'est engagé avec
les organismes puisque vous avec des
organismes sont maîtres de leur
politique de ressources humaines mais un
dialogue qui s'est engagé pour qu'il y
ait un juste équilibre nous y
reviendrons entre l' embauche de jeunes
chercheurs parce qu'il faut aussi ouvrir
la porte au post doc parce que c'est ça
notre avenir
et puis la titrisation de personnes de
personnels qui sont pas très bien traité
en particulier pour le personnel
technique je le dis aux ingénieurs de
recherche et qui sont très mal et de cdd
parfois en cdd depuis plusieurs années
ce qui n'est effectivement pas tolérable
et le tout avec un budget augmenté de 2
2% ce qui en fait la plus grosse
augmentation tout de même depuis ces
dernières années et la création de 5000
postes ça n'a pas été le cas depuis plus
de dix ans la dernière augmentation
remonte à 2006 je crois avec seulement
600 postes
donc vous voyez que les moyens sont au
rendez-vous alors y'a jamais assez de
moyens bien entendu mais il ya tout de
même des moyens qui sont identifiés qui
sont chiffrés qui sont engagés qui sont
gravées dans dans le marbre des
décisions
et puis nous avons une loi d'orientation
avec des débats qui je l'espère seront
le plus ouvert le plus serein possible
parce que je crois que c'est dans cet
état d'esprit qu'il nous faut envisager
l'avenir et ceux qui me connaissent
savent que je suis une ministre issu du
terrain pas dogmatique et ouverte aux
différents points de vue pour peu qu'ils
servent l'intérêt général donc je vous
remercie d'avoir bien voulu permettre ce
débat merci madame le ministre
à l'article 1er biche donc lady deux
amendements discussion commune
d'amendements 312 grammes en croissance
même si vous madame laborde qui les
présente et vous présenter les deux en
même temps ou l'un d'eux sur président
madame la miss mes chers collègues
l'état doit garantir l'égalité de tous
les citoyens devant le service public de
l'éducation
tous les jeunes doivent pouvoir quelle
que soit la partie du territoire de la
république
avoir accès à une formation
d'enseignement supérieur de son choix a
priori l'article premier du projet de
loi satisfait en partie cette obligation
dans les faits les jeunes résidant en
zone rurale subissent une orientation
par défaut en poursuivant une formation
professionnelle ou qui tout simplement
le système scolaire
l'implantation d'antennes universitaire
d'iut ou des futures écoles supérieures
du professorat d'éducation fait vivre
les territoires ruraux ne l'oublions pas
l'implantation des services publics
participent pleinement à l'aménagement
et l'attractivité de nos territoires
ainsi afin de renforcer le qualité de
ces territoires
cet amendement a pour objet de fixer par
décret un pourcentage de création
d'établissements d'enseignement
supérieur réservé aux zones rurales et
pour le l'amendement 311 je dirais que
nous sommes en rds des provinciaux avec
de fortes zones rurales et donc dans le
même esprit que le précédent amendement
il est possible proposé d'inscrire dans
la loi que le maintien ou le
développement des formations supérieures
est privilégiée dans les zones rurales
je vous remercie
si avis de la commission sur ces deux
amendements madame heures
alors c'est un avis défavorable monsieur
le président car justement le fait que
l'état soit le garant de l'égalité
devant le service public et mise en
oeuvre par une stratégie nationale de
l'enseignement supérieur basé sur la
concertation pour aborder ces sujets et
donc l'inscrire dans la loi dès qu'un
décret le prévoir et ce serait
outrepasser cette liberté de dialogue
conférer justement à l'élaboration de la
stratégie nationale et à sa mise en
oeuvre et pour le 311
là évidemment on peut être tout à fait
d'accord sur l'idée de maintenir le
service public dans les zones rurales
bien évidemment mais il serait là aussi
inadaptée de prévoir ça dès la loi alors
que cette priorité ne peut s'inscrire
que dans le cadre de la stratégie
nationale définie dans là dedans la
concertation la plus large
merci madame le ministre à vis de deux
amendements même avis pour les mêmes
raisons avec l'affirmation d'une
préoccupation pour que l'ensemble du
territoire continu être érigée par les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
et également de recherche parce qu'il
peut y avoir des niches d'excellence
dans certains pôles considéré comme des
petits poule je ne veux pas dire pôles
secondaires parce que c'est péjoratif
mais aussi une explication de vote
écoutez je pense que l'on va bien
commencer cette matinée et donc ayant
grande confiance sur la ministre au nom
des rdse j'accepte de retirer cet
amendement parce que je sais que ce qui
est dit et écrit et ça évitera d'avoir
un avis donc défavorable et un vote
défavorable mais je vraiment qu'il soit
inscrit dans le compte rendu que madame
la ministre est très attentive aux zones
rurales heureux parce que c'est quand
même une majorité de zones en france les
villes et les territoires ruraux
c'est quand même deux poids deux mesures
et donc j'ai bien entendu que ce ne
serait pas deux poids deux mesures les
deux amendements vous retirer vous
retirez les deux madame laborde que de
lui dire je vais donc mettre aux voix
l'article 1er bis
l'explication de vote je ne vois pas ce
qu'ils sont favorables cet article bien
levé la main
ceux qui sont défavorables il est adopté
article 2 je suis saisi de trois
demandes de prise de parole madame
claudine lepage
vous avez la parole la chapellerie merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues nous en sommes donc à
l'examen de l'article 2 du projet de loi
article qui suscite tant d'émoi et sur
lequel se sont focalisés les débats
pourquoi une telle effervescence autour
de cette disposition
elle propose d'introduire une nouvelle
exception au principe qui fait du
français la langue de l'enseignement des
examens des concours et des thèses mais
de grâce coupons court d'emblée à tout
fantasme d'anglicisation irréversible et
galopant de l'université française nous
n'avons rien à gagner de cette
détestable défense de la francophonie
par la peur qui fait florès ces
dernières semaines il va de soi que le
français demeure a bel et bien la langue
de l'enseignement dans notre pays
la nouvelle rédaction de l'article 2
adoptée par notre commission ne laisse
aucun doute sur la volonté du
législateur d'encadrer strictement cette
exception mais surtout l'article précise
clairement que les étudiants bénéficiant
de ces cours en langues étrangères
suivent également des cours de culture
et de langue française et que
conformément à l'un des amendements que
j'avais déposé en commission
leur niveau de maîtrise la langue
française est évalué pour l'obtention du
diplôme soit à l'occasion d'un examen ou
d'un contrôle continu
ainsi l'objectif de cette mesure et
réaffirmées sans ambiguïté ne pas faire
de la maîtrise de la langue française un
prêt requis à la poursuite d'études en
france tout en subordonnant l'obtention
du diplôme à une évaluation de
l'apprentissage du français
dans ces conditions nous sommes bien
loin du rand du renoncement à la défense
de la langue française
ces étudiants quelle que soit leur
parcours ultérieure diffuseront notre
langue et notre culture et seront ainsi
des vecteurs du multilinguisme en
général et de la francophonie en
particulier à laquelle nous sommes
attachés ne se croit un autre garde-fou
s'il en était besoin est mise en place
en effet un rapport du gouvernement sera
remis au parlement
trois ans après la promulgation
de la loi pour évaluer l'impact dans les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
de l'article 2 sur l'emploi du français
l'évolution de l'offre de formation en
langues la mise en place l'enseignement
de la langue et de la culture françaises
vers les étudiants étrangers et aussi
l'évolution de l'offre d'enseignement en
français dans des établissements
étrangers la france perpétue une longue
tradition d'accueil et de rayonnement
culturel et scientifique mise à mal ces
dernières années l'abrogation de la
circulaire guéant dès l'élection de
françois hollande à constituer un
premier pas vers la reconquête de la 3e
place mondiale de notre pays pour
l'accueil des étudiants étrangers
ces étudiants étrangers les africains en
constituent la moitié sont les premiers
ambassadeurs de la francophonie et il
constitue assurément un levier de notre
croissance et de celle de l'europe
mais outre l'afrique il importe de nous
tourner vers d'autres directions et
notamment vers les brics dont les
ressortissants sont quasiment absents
des bancs de nos universités
pourtant c'est bien notamment en
intensifiant l'internet l'internal si
oui voilà et les partenariats deux
universités que la france retrouvera une
réelle compétitivité en attirant les
meilleurs étudiants internationaux mais
aussi en diversifiant leur origine
géographique au-delà de notre zone
d'influencé traditionnelle qu'est
l'afrique francophone
elle est essentielle mais pourquoi se
priver des autres nous n'avons pas les
moyens de manquer le coche au delà même
de l'attractivité universitaire de la
france l'enjeu est stratégique pour
notre politique d' influence à travers
le monde
c'est bien cette possibilité d'un
enseignement en anglais ou une autre
langue à côté d'un apprentissage du
français qui permettra d'élargir encore
le le socle de la culture francophone en
accueillant et en formant en français
des étudiants qui s'orientent jusqu'à
présent vers les universités anglo
saxonnes simplement parce que comme
beaucoup ils n'ont pas eu l'occasion
d'apprendre notre langue
au cours de leur cursus secondaire merci
madame michèle andré monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues
l'ambition du projet de loi qui nous est
proposé est réel est certes plus large
que l'article 2 qui étend les exceptions
au principe de l'enseignement en langue
française dans les écoles et universités
mais ce n'est pas par hasard qu'il a
cristallisé les débats suscité d'âpres
controverse tant dans les médias qu'à
l'assemblée nationale et ceci toutes
sensibilités politiques confondues
ces discussions ont au moins eu le
mérite de permettre à de nombreuses
personnes de mieux cerner les enjeux
la langue n'est pas seulement un moyen
de communication elle véhicule surtout
et aussi les valeurs auxquelles nous
sommes attachés auquel nous croyons et
que nous défendons mais je dois vous le
dire l'article 2 du projet de
réinitialiser autorise d'enseignement
supérieur dans une langue étrangère
m'avait interpellé en raison tout
d'abord d'une certaine confusion autour
de l'objectif chercher ton à améliorer
la maîtrise des langues étrangères en
fait essentiellement l'anglais par les
jeunes français alors vous le savez bien
c'est au niveau de l'enseignement
primaire et secondaire que l'essentiel
des efforts doivent porter ne confondons
pas apprentissage de l'anglais et
apprentissage en anglais l'objectif est
utile d'attirer les étudiants étrangers
en beaucoup plus grand nombre dans le
contexte d'un marché international de
l'enseignement supérieur sur lequel la
formation en français finirait presque
par être considérée comme un handicap
un proverbe chinois dit quand le sage
désigne la lune l'idiot regarde le doigt
et certains ont parfois eu tendance à
ringardiser ce débat comme si les
défendeurs de la langue française
désignée le doit au lieu de regarder
vers la lune présenté comme le sésame de
l'attractivité de nos établissements
d'enseignement supérieur mais sommes
nous certains que l'apprentissage de
notre langue constitue bien le frein
majeur du choix de ces jeunes étrangers
des aiguilles en chinois par exemple de
plus en plus nombreux na prend-il pas le
français en six mois avant leur arrivée
dans une université française ils
contribuent d'ailleurs ainsi au
financement de nos alliances françaises
cette question doit être considéré dans
sa globalité les freins l'attractivité
universitaires françaises tiennent très
largement aux insuffisances de l'accueil
des étudiants étrangers dans notre pays
visent à compliquer ou refuser logement
difficile
l'accompagnement insuffisant méandres
bureaucratiques tout cela est bien plus
rude que la langue de voltaire de camus
de césaire de léopold sédar senghor
d'houphouët-boigny de norodom sihanouk
et de kundera
nous en avons d'ailleurs bien conscience
puisque nous avons d'ores et déjà adopté
des mesures pour améliorer la situation
je pense en particulier à l'abrogation
de la circulaire guéant
nous sommes sur la bonne voie et je m'en
réjouis car à mes yeux il s'agit là
d'une priorité
mais combien de jeunes sénégalais
burkinabé tchadiens formés dans nos
excellents lycée français ont pris le
chemin de montréal new york ou boston
faute d'avoir pu obtenir un visa je suis
bien sûr sensible aux arguments
pragmatique
d'après campusfrance 795 programme
propose déjà des programmes en anglais
dont 165 exclusivement dans cette langue
mais raisonnons un instant termes
différents sommes nous réellement
compétitifs sur cette offre finalement
banale puisque proposé par quasiment
tous les autres pays occidentaux ne
devrions nous pas perfectionner notre
offre sur ce marché de niche et
améliorer l'accueil des étudiants
étrangers je pense aussi un plus fort
soutien à la diffusion des publications
scientifiques en français dans les
disciplines où l'anglais n'est pas
incontournable vers vous le savez bien
la langue véhicule aussi les concepts et
la culture au sens large mais j'ai
craint surtout que nous envoyons un
signal très négatif aux 116 millions de
personnes qui dans le monde entier sur
tous les continents apprennent le
français ou apprennent en français car
nous portons là une responsabilité
spécifique mes fonctions au sein de la
pf me montre à quel point nos débats et
décisions sur ce point sont scrutés par
nos amis francophones
il s'étonne et s'inquiète lorsqu'ils ont
le sentiment que nous-mêmes renonçons à
notre langue comme le disait hier encore
un industriel québécois n'en
sous-estimons pas l'impact en termes de
moindre motivation des élèves étrangers
apprendre le français s'il pensait que
cela n'était plus utile dans leur cursus
toute la filière de formation est
concerné c'est pourquoi je me réjouis
très sincèrement madame la ministre
et je vous remercie de l'accueil que
vous nous avez réservé au titre de la pf
des améliorations apportées au projet de
loi initial temps par nos collègues
députés que par notre connaissance
notre commission de la culture et de
l'éducation l'article de été précisé
les exceptions la loi toubon sont
encadrés claudine lepage l'a développé
je n'y reviendrai pas l'article 2 bis
prévoit qu'un rapport évaluera l'impact
de l'article de très bien l'article 8
comporte désormais des dispositions de
promotion de la francophonie c'est
essentiel non la francophonie n'est pas
un débat d'arrière garde et nous ne
sommes pas dans une sorte de combat des
anciens contre les modernes
je crois qu'avec l'ensemble des
améliorations aussi adopté et peut-être
une attention un amas des amendements
qui vont arriver
nous pouvons nous réconcilier autour de
notre ambition commune et non
contradictoire de promotion de notre
enseignement supérieur et dans notre
langue
mais chaque collègue je souhaite que nos
débats sans prendre tout l'espace sur
cette loi madame la ministre
permettent d'éclairer à la fois nos
concitoyens et nos amis des pays
francophones de les convaincre que nous
ne baissons pas les bras dans ce domaine
loin s'en faut je vous remercie
merci mes chers collègues monsieur
jacques legendre sur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues on parle
de modifier la loi toubon
encore faut-il regarder ce que dit la
loi toubon
j'étais en 1994 le rapporteur de cette
loi au sénat donc j'en garde le souvenir
et je suis allé revoir très clairement
ce qu'elle permet est ce qu'elle ne
permet pas la loi toubon n'est pas
destiné à empêcher tout usage d'une
autre langue
en france l institut simplement dans
notre pays un droit aux français qui
garantit à nos concitoyens un égal accès
à l'information et au savoir dans son
article 11
cette loi du 4 août 1994 dit que le
français la langue de l'enseignement des
examens des concours des thèses et
mémoires dans les établissements publics
et privés d'enseignement avec déjà deux
exception justifiée pour l'enseignement
des langues et cultures régionales ou
étrangères et pour l'enseignement
dispensé par des professeurs étrangers
ou invités étrangers
la circulaire d'application du 19 mars
96 précise que sont visés les formations
dispensées en langues régionales ou
étrangères dans le cadre des sections
européennes
ou à vocation bilingue et représentant
au maximum 50 % du volume total des
enseignements de ces sections
voilà des précisions utiles par ailleurs
et là j'attire votre attention
la circulaire d'application dispose que
les écoles étrangères ou spécialement
ouvertes pour accueillir des étrangers
de nationalité des étudiants de
nationalité étrangère ne sont pas soumis
à l'obligation du français ne sont pas
soumis à l'obligation du français il y
est donc clair que la loi sur la langue
française ne fait nullement obstacle à d
enseignement en langue étrangère pour
des étudiants non francophones c'est
déjà dans le texte est déjà dans la
circulaire d'application
alors où est le problème est ce que
c'est la volonté de faire en sorte que
tous les jeunes français maîtrisent bien
les langues étrangères
nous partageons tous cette volonté et sa
relève
bien évidemment d'abord de
l'enseignement primaire et de
l'enseignement secondaire est d'ailleurs
la loi toubon elle même dit dans son
article 11 la maîtrise de la langue
française et la connaissance de deux
autres langues font partie des objectifs
fondamentaux de l'enseignement et bien
que cette loi n'est pas une loi
restrictive centré sur le sol français
le problème mes chers collègues c'est
que l'on veut être autorisées à
enseigner intégralement en anglais à des
jeunes français ou francophones et que
pour y parvenir
depuis quelques années certains sont
avancer masqué
je vais prendre un exemple très précis
et je le tire d'une de la presse il
s'agit d'une grande école installée dans
un département qui nous est chère madame
la présidente de la commission de la
culture et qui se réjouit d'avoir obtenu
des
reconnaissance internationale qui vont
la placer dans l'élite mondiale des
business schools je m'en réjouis
et que fait cette école elle a deux
campus à lille et à paris la défense
elle précise que 800 de ces trois mille
cent étudiants et 84% de ses professeurs
sont étrangers et que l'enseignement qui
y est dispensé intégralement en anglais
est ce que ça ne pose pas quand même mes
chers collègues un problème l'amendement
adopté à l'assemblée nationale les
inquiéter et qu'est ce qu'un des
dirigeants à s'est permis de dire
récemment à une agence française de
presse spéciale et dans les questions
d'éducation
l'aef ce qu'on faisait était déjà
contraire à la loi la loi change
nous continuerons à être parfois dans
l'illégalité
personne ne va ni venir nous embêter là
dessus alors vous comprendrez mes chers
collègues que je ne fantasme pas que je
n'ai pas d'inquiétude ringarde et
particulière mais que je crois que le
parlement doit se préoccuper de
l'application des lois votées par le
parlement
jamais posé une question écrite à madame
la ministre de la de la culture puisque
c'est elle qui suit
l'application du français en france à
propos de ce que j'appelais une
violation caractérisée de la loi sur la
langue française et qui concernait une
école rouennaise qui entendait
développer des cours de management
culturel et qui dans ce domaine du
management culturel entendait donner
tous ces cours également en anglais
réponse de madame filippetti elles
jugent inopportun le choix d'un
enseignement exclusivement dispensés en
anglais sous le couvert de modernité
elle a bien raison
et elle précise ensuite la ministre
considère qu'il n'y a pas lieu de
laisser penser aux étudiants que
l'anglais la seule langue comprise à
l'international un tel parti pris
continue à affaiblir la position du
français sur le plan international et
découragent tous ceux qui parient sur
son avenir ou font l'effort de
l'apprendre le recours à une langue qui
n'est pas celle de nos concitoyens
laisse entendre implicitement que le
français aurait perdu toute
fonctionnalité à l'international un
enseignement respectueux de notre langue
tout en étant compréhensible par les
non-francophones reste préférable et ne
compromet en rien l'image d'excellence
et dynamisme et des écoles de commerce
françaises
mes chers collègues compte tenu de tous
ces éléments je partage tout à fait la
déclaration d'anne filippetti je vous
proposerai dans quelques instants
un amendement qui clarifie les choses
qui distingue bien la situation des
étudiants francophones et étudiants non
francophones et qui nous protègent
contre la volonté dissimulé de faire en
sorte que le français ne soient plus
pour tous les jeunes français
la première langue de l'éducation en
france si la parole est à mme gonthier
maurin
monsieur le président madame à ministre
mes chers collègues l'article l 121 3 du
code de l'éducation fait du français la
langue de l'enseignement des examens des
concours et des thèses alors qu'il
prévoit déjà des possibilités
d'exception justifiées par les
nécessités de l'enseignement des langues
et cultures régionales ou étrangères ou
lorsque les enseignants sont des
professeurs associés ou était étranger
l'article 2 du projet de loi souhaite
rajout en rajouter de nouvelles une
exception liée aux nécessités
pédagogique relative à l'accueil et
l'information des étudiants étrangers
dans le cadre des accords internationaux
une autre liée au développement de
cursus et diplômes trans frontaliers
multilingue
l'objectif serait de développer
l'attractivité des universités
françaises pour les étrangers
permettez-nous de douter de l'utilité de
cette mesure alors que comme le rappelle
le dernier rapport du secrétariat
général à l'immigration et à
l'intégration
la france se situe dans une situation
honorable dans la compétition mondiale
pour attirer les étranges les étudiants
étrangers
elle occupe le cinquième rang mondial
elles mêmes avec l'allemagne le pays
le premier pays non anglophones
d'accueil de ces étudiants étrangers
cette place honore notre pays dans sa
tradition d'ouverture et représente
l'une des plaies de notre influence
scientifique culturelle et politique
dans le monde
nous accueillons en effet près de 290
1000 étudiants qui représente plus de
15% des inscrits cela signifie que le
rayonnement de l'université française ne
dépend pas de la langue enseignée et n'a
pas de relation avec le fait d'enseigner
en français il tient avant tout à la
qualité de notre service public de
l'enseignement supérieur à la renommée
de notre recherche publique et de nos
formations à caractère technique qui
attire notamment la plus forte propose
porto proportion d'étudiants étrangers
comme c'est le cas dans les instituts
nationaux polytechniques et dans les
universités de technologie
l'extension de cette exception nous
paraît en outre constituer une entorse
grave aux principes de la loi toubon
sous prétexte de développer
l'attractivité internationale
cet article de loi permettrait aux
étudiants français de bénéficier des
mêmes exceptions l'hégémonie de la
langue anglaise ne doit pas nous amener
à faire reculer la place de notre langue
au sein de notre système universitaire
au contraire un des moyens du maintien
du rayonnement de notre langue et de
notre culture passe par sa réaffirmation
et ce a fortiori quand elle concerne des
étudiants étrangers venus étudier en
france il est vrai que certains
étudiants étrangers choisissent la
france non pas pour le pays la langue
mais en raison de frais d'inscription à
l'université trop importants dans les
pays anglo saxons mais cela signifie
t'il pour autant que nous devons alors
abandonner notre langue
je ne crois pas bien au contraire il
faut y voir là une opportunité de
diffuser notre langue notre culture de
valoriser la franconie la con la
francophonie à travers le monde de
renforcer notre place notre influence
développer notre astre attractivité pour
les étudiants étrangers passent d'abord
par l'amélioration des conditions et des
moyens d'accueil à l'université de ses
étudiants au même titre que nos
étudiants français que ce soit dans le
cadre de
la relance de notre parc de logements
universitaires ou dans la modernisation
de nos équipements universitaires et de
recherche
notre rayonnement repose également sur
notre capacité à promouvoir à l'étranger
notre modèle d'enseignement supérieur à
travers notre diplomatie culturelle et
d' influence si nous fûmes les premiers
à mettre en place et s'il constitue
encore le réseau le plus dense et le
plus étendu via les espaces campus
france qui s'étend dans 110 pays
les investissements français dans ce
domaine diminue alors que tous les
autres pays notamment les pays émergents
chine brésil investissent massivement
dans ce domaine conscient de
l'importance stratégique de la promotion
de leur langue et de leur culture
il faut aussi avoir une vision large de
l'avenir de la promotion de la langue de
la république qui est le français
l'enseignement supérieur public a ici
toute sa place à soutenir cette
promotion en france à ses étudiants
étrangers et à l'autre bout du monde je
vous remercie
je demande prise de parole dans mon
passé aux deux amendements qui sont en
discussion commune le premier amendement
26 madame gonthier-maurin c'est vous qui
présentait le lam
je poursuis j'ai déjà exprimé les
raisons de notre position à cet article
2 qui est en plus que de raison les
exceptions à la loi toubon notre
amendement propose donc de supprimer cet
article est de limiter les exceptions au
cas déjà prévues par la loi afin de ne
pas aboutir à une marginalisation de
notre langue nous ne pensons pas qu'il
faille entériné la tendance qui fait de
l'anglais la langue unique et
internationale lalande n'est pas
seulement un moyen d'expression
elle est aussi un système de pensée de
culture reconnaître une langue unique
c'est accepter l'uniformisation des
modes de vie la culture à sion au
bénéficie au bénéfice de la culture dont
elle est issue
la chine l'a bien compris elle qui
investit massivement dans le
développement d'instituts confucius à
travers le monde pour valoriser sa
langue sa culture la langue et donc un
enjeu de puissance tout empiètement
d'une langue par rapport à une autre
correspondant quart
deux cultures et d' influence il faut
évidemment que les étudiants français
maîtrisent l'anglais comme d'autres
langues étrangères c'était une nécessité
mais il faut pour cela revaloriser
l'enseignement des langues étrangères
depuis l'école primaire jusqu'à
l'université
dans le cadre de cours dédiés à cet
apprentissage et non pas par des cours
enseignés en langue étrangère
il faut mener le combat de la diversité
et du multilinguisme et c'est celui que
nous proposons d'engager en votant la
suppression de cet article merci
j'ai donc cédé d'amendements 260
rectifié monsieur legembre jeu le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues il vous est proposé de
supprimer l'amendement à l'article 2
tels qu'ils résultent du texte qui a été
adopté finalement par la commission de
la culture de notre assemblée
le débat avait commencé à l'assemblée
nationale et les députés s'étaient
inquiétés eux aussi de ces amendements à
la loi toubon et il avait proposé une
rédaction dans là qu'ils autorisent est
partiellement l'usagé d'une langue
étrangère pour des cours destinés aux
jeunes français
l'amendement tel qu'il a été proposé par
notre rapporteur au sénat est adoptée a
d'une manière à priori sympathique et
plus claires indiqué qu'elle ou rappeler
quels étaient les règles d'usagé du
français dans la dans la dans ce texte
mais il a fait disparaître ce qui est à
le mot essentiel partiellement si bien
que nous risquons non pas d'avoir
contribuer à refermer en corse que
l'association avait déjà commencé à
encadrer mais nous risquons cette fois
ci de voir les brèches se réouvrir car
je le répète nous avons affaire à des
personnes qui ont créé des formations
dans l'illégalité et en toute
connaissance de cause et qui ne se cache
pas de vouloir continuer il faut donc
que notre rédaction soit très précises
voilà pourquoi je vous propose de
supprimer l'amendement dans ce texte
actuel de manière à pouvoir présenter
ensuite une nouvelle disposition qui
soient plus claires et plus précise et à
éviter à l'avenir les errements sur la
langue je voyais enfin combien ce débat
mme parent important j'ai retrouvé
récemment dans la plume d'un écrivain du
siècle des lumières celui où le français
était la grande langue de l'europe
une remarque qui me paraît très
pertinente une langue ne peut être
dominante sans que les idées qu'elle
transmet ne prennent un grand ascendant
sur les esprits et une nation qui
parlent une autre langue que la sienne
père insensiblement son caractère voilà
ce qu'il faut éviter pour les élites
françaises
merci mon cher collègue avis de la
commission même ce sont deux amendements
monsieur le président madame la ministre
moi j'ai bien écouté avait enfin j'ai
écouté avec attention les différentes
interventions
mais je vous encourage quand même les
orateurs à relire l'article de tel qu'il
a été écrit le français reste bien la
langue de l'enseignement et la langue
des examens il n'est pas du il n'y a pas
de renoncement à la défense à la
diffusion de la langue française bien au
contraire
accueillir des étudiants leurs enfants
des cours dans leur langue pour qu'il ne
soit pas trop dépaysé participe d'une
attention qui favorise leur intégration
si on veut élargir l'accueil des
étudiants étrangers au brésilien ou aux
indiens il faut vraiment développer des
langues dans lesquelles ils se
découvrent dans lesquelles ils seront à
l'aise ils commenceront à à s'inspirer à
apprécier la culture française c'est une
démarche d'attention à leur égard et
donc je pense que par 7 7 cet article 2
nous allons accueillir des francophiles
et nous allons en faire des francophones
grâce justement aux cours de langue
française au cours de culture française
et ensuite
fort de cet accueil ils repartiront
ambassadeur de la culture française
c'est un moyen me semble-t-il
de mieux développer le rayonnement de
notre université le rayonnement de la
france à l'étranger
et même si la barrière de la langue
n'est pas le seul obstacle au choix des
étudiants étrangers nous le savons bien
ça a été rappelé on aura l'occasion d'en
rediscuter dans le cours de la
discussion
rien ne dit qu'elle n'en est pas un donc
je pense que tout ce qui fait que tout
ce qu'il fait signal de bon accueil
d'ouverture d'attention à l'accueil des
étudiants étrangers
eh bien il faut le faire et il n'est dit
nulle part qu'il s'agit d'une
généralisation de l'anglais il peut y
avoir bien au contraire du portugal de
l'espagnol de l'allemand il ya
d'ailleurs des universités qui ont mis
en place des doubles diplômes et j'ai la
liste là des universités qui diffuse
dispensant d enseignement en langue
étrangère dispense les mêmes
enseignements en français de telle sorte
que les étudiants ont un double diplôme
donc là il n'y a pas de raison de
craindre 7,7 cette ouverture cet article
2 et moi je l'aimais un avis au nom de
la commission je maintiens l'avis
défavorable à la suppression de cet
article
merci madame madame le ministre s'il
vous plaît oui je partage l'avis de la
rapporteure naturellement et je remercie
d'ailleurs l'assemblée nationale et
votre commission au sénat d'avoir amené
les garanties nécessaires qui était de
nature je crois à apaiser les
préoccupations légitimes elles sont
toujours légitimes les préoccupations
quand on les expriment qui est qu'ils
ont pu qui ont pu s'exprimer
je voudrais tout de même amené un petit
correctif sur la situation favorable de
la france nous étions second dans
l'accueil des étudiants étrangers
nous sommes nous avons été troisième
nous sommes maintenant 5e et nous sommes
fait attraper par des pays qui accueille
justement ces étudiants des pays
émergents et ses étudiants scientifiques
donc pour autant nous allons leur
dispenser des cours de français et leur
maîtrise du français sera prise en
compte dans
l'attribution du diplôme donc je crois
que nous sommes arrivés un bon équilibre
et je crois aussi qu'il nous faut
redoubler d'efforts vis-à-vis des pays
francophones notamment l'afrique
subsaharienne et le maghreb avec des
relations plus équilibrées avec ces pays
et non plus des relations j'allais dire
post coloniale où on accueillait
seulement les étudiants mais avec des
relations plus équilibrées
nous nous installons la bad et des
déformations et où nous envoyons
également des étudiants français dans
ces pays
parce que je vous le dis mesdames et
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
l'afrique sera peut-être notre salut à
nous européens
je crois que l'afrique un pays est un
pays jeune est un pays plein d'énergie
est un pays qui connaît un des
pourcentages de de croissance de 5% est
un pays qui détient des matières rares
et nous avons un intérêt culturel une
responsabilité culturelle historique
mais nous avons aussi un intérêt
économique à multiplier à développer des
relations équilibrées avec les pays
d'afrique subsaharienne
et puis par ailleurs nous allons
améliorer mais on aura l'occasion d'en
parler
l'accueil des étudiants étrangers à
l'étranger en matière de visas cela a
été dit et en matière notamment cela
dédié à l'assemblée nationale et au
sénat parce que nous avons eu un débat
sur l'attractivité de notre pays en
matière notamment de l'attribution de
visas pluriannuels dans des conditions
qui seront similaires à celles des
étudiants bourses et c'est à dire que
amenant de redoublement sera et demi
parce qu'on peut admettre que pour des
étudiants étrangers ils soient plus
difficile que pour d'autres de réussir
ses examens
je crois que nous sommes arrivés à une
proposition équilibrée qui respecte les
différents points de vue qui respecte
les équilibres et qui évite que de
manière totalement injuste des écoles
aujourd'hui s'affranchisse de la halle
delà des dispositions de la loi toubon
puisque sur les 790 formation 6 ans sont
dispensés dans des écoles et vous l'avez
dit à juste titre monsieur legendre et
des écoles qui s'affranchissent de la
loi pour des établissements qui forment
les jeunes je trouve ça particulièrement
fâcheuse et donc d'une certaine manière
il s'agit d'établir aussi une équité
entre
les jeunes qui sont à l'université qui
aurait dû apprendre les langues
étrangères
je suis d'accord il s'agit de pas de ça
ici de façon plus plus heureuse d'aider
la maternelle c'est ce qui va se faire
avec le projet de loi qu'a défendu
vincent peillon
mais il s'agit aussi de donner aux
jeunes à l'université l'opportunité de
rencontrer des jeunes issus des pays
émergents avec lesquels ensuite ils
pourront développer des relations des
relations culturelles des relations
commerciales au bénéfice des emplois et
je trouve que ça c'est une bonne chose
parce qu'il y avait tout de même une
disproportion entre les élèves dans les
haies les jeunes les étudiants dans les
écoles qui sont souvent issus de milieux
plus favorisés 54% un enfant de cadre
dans les classes prépas et puis les
étudiants à l'université qui sont
souvent issus de milieux plus modestes
qui ont eu moins l'opportunité de
développer les codes qui sont à
l'international qui sont utiles dans un
cv dans une insertion professionnelle
réussie donc s'arrêter a rétabli une
certaine manière une certaine aussi
justice sociale et puis ça régulariser
situation tout en les encadrant et ça va
être plus difficile je me permets de le
dire aux au sénateur legendre et la
sénatrice michèle andré ça va être plus
compliqué aujourd'hui pour les écoles
que ça ne l'était auparavant donc d'une
certaine manière on encadre davantage là
l'enseignement de langue étrangère pas
seulement en langue étrangère pas
seulement en anglais et des cours de
droit roman en allemand à tour par
exemple mais cela rendra les choses
davantage encadré donc je vous invite
tout de même à rejeter l'amendement de
suppression et au contraire engager un
débat sur cette disposition qui me
paraît d'ouverture de justice sociale et
d'encadrement finalement de ce qui suit
aujourd'hui de façon assez débridée et
assez injuste entre écoles et
universités merci madame le ministre
j'ai donc mettre en boîte du mandement
nous interrompons cette séance pour une
édition